I would like to face and face to face
someday I'd like to see if at some point
he would break and admit to what he's
done
so I would meet with I would like to me
what a myself
we came today not to free you from your
prison but to free us from our prison no
one knows our fears and our daily
struggles today I am closing the door to
my pain today this is it
I'm letting go so you let go of your
truth you're gonna stay in your mental
prison forever and that's sad he just
don't realize by talking about what he's
done what a release that would be for
him he would find spiritual freedom for
himself and I'm left I just feel bad for
I've been hurt too
we have a constitutional right to a fair
trial I was denied it
[Music]